este joven acaba de ser sacado de los
escombros sus dos manos fueron vendadas
su cara aún se ve negra por el polvo
todos los pasillos del hospital de
hardcore están llenos de heridos que
sobrevivieron los bombardeos de las
fuerzas rusas
esta mujer aún en estado de shock no se
recupera
pero tales de farra roja estábamos
escondidos en el garaje cuando nos
bombardearon me golpearon en la cabeza
los heridos pertenecen a las zonas
residenciales de jarkko que desde hace
días son atacadas por el ejército ruso
la segunda ciudad más grande de ucrania
quedó prácticamente irreconocible tras
los bombardeos este hombre busca sus
pertenencias entre los escombros
las lágrimas corren por mis mejillas y
eso que soy un antiguo soldado ayer mi
esposa fue herida por una bomba ahora
está en el hospital la han salvado con
dificultades listo
los trabajadores del hospital también
luchan por contener sus emociones ante
el constante flujo de nuevas llegadas
animal tóxico a 114 puesto pottermore
aquí todos los pacientes que aún pueden
caminar quieren volver con sus familias
los que ya no pueden caminar se quedan
aquí
y muy útil pero
por desgracia ya no podemos contarlos a
veces hay calma a veces estamos
desbordados
según el último balance de la onu más de
800 civiles han resultado heridos desde
que comenzó la invasión rusa hace casi 2
semanas